شيع في بيروت جثمان نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس صالح العاروري وجثمان
القائد في كتائب القسام عزام الاقرع
والعنصر في حركه حماس محمد الريس هنا في
بيروت وكانوا قد اغتيلوا في الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي لمكتب حركه حماس في الضحيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت يوم الثلاثاء مراسم
التشييع قد لقت من مسجد الامام علي في
الطريق الجديده باتجاه منطقه شتيله وصولا
الى مدافن الشهداء طبعا اقيمت صلاه
الجنازه في مسجد الامام علي وسد حشود
كثيفه شاركت في التشيع وطبعا اطلقت
الهتافات المندده بالجريمه الاسرائيليه
والمطالبه بالرد عليها وايضا رفعت الاعلام
اعلام الفصائل الفلسطينيه وال الكلمات
التي القيت في هذه المناسبه شددت على ان
المواجهه مع الجيش الاسرائيلي هي مواجهه
مفتوحه طبعا عمليه اغتيال العاروري وسته
اخرين من بينهم قائدان في كتائب القسام قد
تمت بصواريخ اسرائيليه استهدفت مكتب لحركه
حماس في قلب الضحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت وكانت هذه العمليه محط استنكار
وادانه من قبل الاطراف السياسيه اللبنانيه
تحديدا حزب الله ومن قبل الحكومه
اللبنانيه التي قررت تقديم شكوى عاجله الى
مجلس الامن ضد اسرائيل بسبب هذه الجريمه
التي نفذتها في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
اذا مراسم الجنازه ومراسم التشيع تتقدم
باتجاه مقبره الشهداء جوني طانيوس الجزيره
بيروت